THE ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN, THE
BIG LIE SOMEHOW STILL LIVES ON.
JOHN AVLON HAS YOUR REALITY
CHECK.
>> IT IS THE MOST DIGITALLY
DOCUMENTED INSURRECTION IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
AND STILL ONE YEAR LATER A
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS BELIEVE
OUTRIGHT LIES, WHILE DONALD
TRUMP REMAINS THE LEADER OF THE
GOP, DESPITE TRYING TO DESTROY
OUR DEMOCRACY TO SATISFY HIS
FRAGILE EGO.
HOW EXACTLY DID THE BIG LIE
METASTASIZE?
TWO FACTORS REALLY.
THE RIGHT WING MEDIA ECHO
CHAMBER THAT PRIMED THE BIG LIE
AND THE ABJECT FAILURE OF
ELECTED REPUBLICAN LEADERS TO
STAND UP TO DONALD TRUMP WHEN
THEY HAD A CHANCE.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
ATTACK ON OUR CAPITOL, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS WERE
UNITED.
WITH FEW SURVEYS FINDING 75% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT TRUMP
BORE SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
ATTACK, WHILE 87% OF U.S. ADULTS
SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE THE PROSECUTION OF
PEOPLE WHO RIOTED THE CAPITOL.
BUT GET THIS, BETWEEN MARCH AND
SEPTEMBER OF 2021, AMERICANS
BECAME LESS LIKELY TO SAY IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO FIND AND PROSECUTE
THE CAPITOL RIOTERS, WITH ALL
THE DECLINE OCCURRING AMONG
REPUBLICANS.
WE KNOW FROM A RECENT WASHINGTON
POST UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND POLL
THAT FOX NEWS REPUBLICAN VIEWERS
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO BELIEVE
THAT TRUMP BEARS NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE JANUARY
6th ATTACK.
THE PEOPLE WHO ATTACKED THE
CAPITOL WERE MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
THAT THE LEGAL PUNISHMENT FOR
THE ATTACKERS HAVE BEEN TOO
HARSH AND THERE IS, QUOTE, SOLID
EVIDENCE OF FRAUD IN THE 2020
ELECTION.
BUT THERE WERE STILL A GLIMMER
OF HOPE WHEN IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THE ATTACK CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICAN LEADERS DENOUNCED
TRUMP FOR INCITING THE RIOT.
>> THE PRESIDENT BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WEDNESDAY'S
ATTACK ON CONGRESS BY MOB
RIOTERS.
HE SHOULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY
DENOUNCED THE MOB WHEN HE SAW
WHAT WAS UNFOLDING.
SOME SAY THE RIOTS WERE CAUSED
BY ANTIFA.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
OF THAT.
AND CONSERVATIVES SHOULD BE THE
FIRST TO SAY SO.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION, NONE,
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PRACTICALLY AND MORALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVOKING THE
EVENTS OF THE DAY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO STORMED THIS
BUILDING BELIEVED THEY WERE
ACTING ON THE WISHES AND
INSTRUCTIONS OF THEIR PRESIDENT.
>> THAT BRIEF MOMENT OF MORAL
CLARITY LOOKS LIKE A MUSEUM
PIECE TODAY.
BECAUSE IT TOOK HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY LESS THAN
A MONTH TO MAKE A RING KISSING
TRIP TO MAR-A-LAGO.
IN STRENUOUS SIGNS OF FEALTY, HE
SCUTTLED LIZ CHENEY FROM
LEADERSHIP, AND THEN TRIED TO
KILL A BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE JANUARY 6th.
THESE APPEASERS NEVER LEARN.
AS CHURCHILL ONCE SAID, IT IS
LIKE BEATING A CROCODILE, HOPING
IT EATS YOU LAST.
THE CASE OF MITCH McCONNELL IS
MORE PERPLEXING.
THE SENATE LEADER IS A FREQUENT
TARGET OF TRUMP'S ATTACKS, AND
McCONNELL REPORTEDLY SAW THE
POST INSURRECTION SECOND
IMPEACHMENT AS A WAY TO FINALLY
RID REPUBLICANS OF TRUMP, BUT AT
A CRITICAL MOMENT HE PULLED THE
PUNCH THAT COULD HAVE STOPPED
TRUMP'S RETURN BY DECIDING TO
OPPOSE THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL,
AND THEN LOBBIED SENATORS TO
BLOCK THE BIPARTISAN JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE AS A PERSONAL FAVOR.
THIS HAD ALL THE HALLMARKS OF A
CYNICAL CALCULUS THAT
REPUBLICANS COULD KEEP TRUMP AT
ARM'S LENGTH, WHILE BENEFITTING
FROM HIS BASE OF SUPPORT.
THIS WAS A DELUSIONAL FANTASY.
AND IT ONLY SUCCEEDED IN
REINFORCING TRUMP'S GRIP ON THE
GOP.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COUNTED MOST,
REPUBLICANS JUST COULDN'T QUIT
THE TWICE IMPEACHED TWO-TIME
POPULAR VOTE LOSER.
FEAR AND GREED AND PARTISAN
CAREERISM CAUSED THEM TO KNUCKLE
UNDER TO THREATS FROM A
DISGRACED AND DEEP PLATFORM
WOULD BE DESPOT.
THIS EMBRACE OF UNREALITY, THE
ASSENT OF THE PARTY OF LINCOLN
TO AN AUTHORITARIAN CURIOUS CULT
OF PERSONALITY, CAN ALSO PROVOKE
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE STRENGTH
AND STABILITY OF OUR DEMOCRACY
AND OUR ABILITY TO REASON
TOGETHER.
BUT REMEMBER, THE BIG LIE
BELIEVING TRUMP REPUBLICANS ARE
A DECIDED MINORITY OF THE
AMERICAN ELECTORATE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
SEE THE TRUTH ABOUT TRUMP'S COUP
ATTEMPT ON JANUARY 6th.
AND THE CLEAR MORAL COST OF
TRYING TO APPEASE BULLIES, THUGS
AND ZEALOTS WILL ONLY BECOME
CLEARER WITH TIME.
THEY WILL BE SEEN AS VILLAINS OR
DUPES.
AS WE AWAIT HISTORY'S JUDGMENT,
AMERICANS WHO PUT PATRIOTISM
OVER PARTISANSHIP MUST RECOGNIZE
THAT RIGHT NOW